[Music]
welcome to YouTube favorite show
scattered a flu you stupid
Dana was nine plus T LaVon I'm Bob Roger
LeBron yeah I'm so far have not left how
about you leave us like them in the
comments so I can know if you liked or
left straight guy James Charles what's
the matter
scared you might like it oh that was
hard I almost laughed on that one what's
happen through this show
[Music]
hey don't Instagram it's big time Tommy
is my thought of the day live the best
life you can thank you thank you so much
how is this real you some freaking
sunscreen Tommy
haters will hate always that's what they
do that's what they hate you know what
they hate themselves even though
Instagram in Des Moines Tommy Dean
[Music]
hey don't Instagram it's big time Tommy
something to remember something to carry
you through this day so far
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
settle down guys
well played Australia I will play that
was beautiful got him I love that you're
out with your girl she accepts a rose
from a random stranger no it's for you
a brofist that's epic that's a gamer
moment it's like air bud but instead of
a dog it's a toad and instead of
basketball at skateboarding what the
Frog is more scape than I ever will
it's like the new Tony Tony Hawk more
like Tony frog
hey more James Charles means everyone
James Charles trying to seduce straight
men into hooking up with snow chowder
[Music]
anemic girls smiling with their eyes
closed are so cute
hey look it's Papa Gloria she is so
adorable too bad she's living on the
streets now thanks to you guys and your
tensile [ __ ] culture disgusting
[Music]
stop
oh stop you ain't cute okay you ain't
cute and know one thing you cute no no
no you look stupid
[Music]
I leave Tech Talk for a week and this is
what you come up with oh my god oh my
god what is happening what is that ah
[Music]
all thank God it's so much thank you can
lay around my household eggs do it goal
goal find a good job
yeah good sausage roll okay bar things
all bad you can't help it fat dog can't
even get a job what is this I've got
three times which is thirty and five
ones so that is 30 plus 512 is 110 you
know people did the teachers did this in
school like this is so much easier if
you do it like this and it's just the
most elaborate thing to ever remember
that no one's ever gonna use as well
okay so that's step one
was there a dog crying in the background
draw a large box she's teaching a dog
how to do math oh my god and you know
the teacher forces you to use his method
too like if you didn't show that you did
her method in the test he wouldn't get
like degrade or
on the side I'm gonna put 10+2 where
your plus signs are I want you to draw
lines through the middle oh my god and
down it and then in the very how long
does this go 35 times 12 you take you
take you take 30 times 10 that way how
would I do this
now you take 35 times 10 and then you
you plus 7350 + cemani it's 424 - I know
swagger soles no you can't snap your
fingers inside your mouth ah oh you [ __ ]
are you going to do it you're good
you're good
a millimeter away actually let me just
make go ahead and make sure the block so
I was playing Minecraft and trying to
build a house and I forgotten that I had
Nicolas Cage texture pack then it
started raining and I freaking screamed
hey hey hey hey
I would die for you oh you all you lose
and I guess that'll work is you work
here help them [ __ ] you mean dumbass
work is you work here help them [ __ ] you
mean dumbass dummy
so where's nice to see people I've
empathy and caring for each other
helping each other
[Music]
my god what
how does that even work
[Music]
they're summoning the genes from the
nebula row
oh my god
take off your jeans right now you could
be possessed is it weird that I kind of
want to lay in front of that laser and
just become jeans can you imagine how
awesome that would be is that you can be
your jeans Oh what is this claim
it's everywhere stop wait a window alarm
you goddamn it memes are so bad right
now we need a good meme guys please it's
just please anything but this see at
least that I can appreciate a funny
creative head I'm kind of
I was just saying like one I'm kind of
what s for water you have a water
alrighty water coming right up
they should have all said in unison that
would have been so great I don't know
what doing
oh god that's great all right they
picked up a bit they picked up a bit I
may have been scratching just a little
bit hand burglar stop god damn it stop
with a hamburger please leave please I
need a good meme review no hamburger
points that came through it
ah so that's another episode of Scott
the new Florida hope you guys had fun I
said I hope you guys had fun Rob the out
room